some of my clients are quite dangerous
we have to go to the police police can't
protect you Ben Affleck plays the
ultimate loner in his new thriller the
accountant but off screen all bed really
wants to do is spend time with his kids
he opened up to our Carly Steele and
talked about his family life when they
sat down today have you ever pulled the
the Hollywood card to get some cool
points with your kids I introduced my
kids to Taylor Swift my two oldest girls
it was like you know God came down and
walked on the water and oh you know and
they didn't say anything they were just
totally frozen how much fun is it for
your kids to get to visit you on this
set it's good to have you know your kids
be I think you know we're what you do
and part of your life it's good for them
to know where I'm going when I go off to
work and what that looks like
the environment is there they're kind of
over it they're not impressed by it or
any school wants to kind of heart now
it's like pulling teeth to get them to
come to the set because they know it's
bored but they they get candy so that's
they like to become free crosser and
since its flashback Friday we had to
bust out this clip from 1984 of a
preteen Ben Oh what I'm the Arctic test
chamber for the United States Army he
was on the educational series the voyage
of the Mimi and his voice had changed
yet have your kids seen it it's Taylor
Swift they're into it you know I mean if
it's like but they my kids I I don't
talk too much about being haven't been a
child actor cuz I don't want them to get
any ideas about you know doing it
themselves today in his newest role in
the accountant he's a bookkeeper for bad
guys turned vigilante the real fun
actually was the training for the fight
scenes and the physicality of it was
really dedicated to try to make the
action as good as realistic as as much
me you know as much and as tense as
possible
you